my cat just decided to jump up hi Cat
hello Cat this was not on purpose I
didn't even know the cat was in the room
there we go how are you guys
doing how are you I'm good listen I and
there's a cat at the door um I'm curious
what is it like for you guys this is not
the way I meant for this all to go so
much better
though this is definitely a unique speed
dating situation with the other
reporters and he's out um so what I'm
curious about is when you have when you
I'm sure you really wanted the role for
both of you but what is it actually like
when Sophia pulls you aside and says you
got it what goes through your brain are
you then all of a sudden like super
excited super nervous or like a
combination of both I think I was on a
high and I felt amazing and I was like
all my dreams have come true and then by
the end of that night I was crying yeah
I was like I don't know how to do this I
can't work with s cou she's my dream
director um but no she she takes all
that pressure off and gives you the
space to to figure it out um along the
way yeah I mean I think it was fear
immediately for me I think I've been
saying I wanted to you know work with
the filmmaker like so fear my whole life
and then she was like okay let's do it
and then I was like oh no no not
actually you know so I know you guys did
a ton of research uh getting ready to
play these roles What were what was some
of the things that you discovered that
really surprised you about their
relationship or just them as people I
feel like one thing that was pretty
prevalent while we were filming was
there was this kind of goofiness to the
pair of them that you could find well
especially for me with with Elvis there
was this very light and jovial side that
was really apparent when you watched
kind of home Home Videos yeah the home
videos are so special to see them on you
know like a Beach vacation and then just
sort of goofing around and they all
had you know they had incredible banter
with each other and um they were just
really they were kids you know I'm
curious so you see the filming schedule
you know what you're shooting and when
or like a rough outline what were the
days what was the day or two that you
had circled because you were super
excited to film it or super nervous to
film it all of all of it I didn't know I
didn't know what was left and right and
of black and white I was so it was my
head was it was hard to keep my head
screwed on straight so I don't I think
we had to take it day by day but was
there a certain moment it was day by day
I think something that came as a bit of
a shock we shot the goodbye scene toward
the end of filming and I think that
day was much heavier than anticipated
for me anyway um it kind of weird shot
their lives leading up to that and that
day came out of nowhere it's only a
brief scene but for me it kind of kind
of flawed me a little bit um having
grown up with them for the you know all
those years and then having to say
goodbye that scene definitely kind of
you know took it took a toll for sure on
that note I already have to stop I'm
just gonna say congrats on the movie you
guys were great good luck with your
speed dating today thank you so
much